that is the Dreaming Joey McIntyre
singing if you go away in 1994 with his
supergroup New Kids on the Block the boy
band had already made history with its
1988 album hangin tough it produced five
billboard top 10 hits and landed the
group on an exclusive list that includes
Michael Jackson Madonna and Bruce
Springsteen
McIntyre has stayed in the forefront of
music and television and he's returning
to TV with return of the Mack Joey plays
a version of himself between jobs and
looking for his next gig
prepping all week this detective series
is perfect for HBO whoa slow your roll
Joe I didn't say it was with HBO I said
it's like HBO
it's a comfy Channel the comfy Channel
I've never even heard of that before
because it is launched bro brand new
network they want to be the HBO for
women
I said no cookies before dinner well
okay whatever they comfy Channel I just
want to get back to work Joey McIntyre
welcome back I did to be back yeah it's
great to have you I've heard I've heard
that you've described the show as Curb
Your Enthusiasm Meets Parenthood meets
episodes yeah kind of yeah kind of I
play it I'd like to thank an exaggerated
form of myself maybe my friends would
think no you're dead-on Joe that's you
but it's it's been fun I mean it's it's
it's a scripted show but my wife was
nice enough to play my wife and she
never acted before and she's amazing in
it so it all worked out it's not just
your wife your kids are also in the show
kids are in it some filming in your own
house
yeah writer on this yeah yourself yeah
fact and fiction ever blur with all this
a little bit a little bit but it's sort
of like I guess the the crux of it is
you know I hope any penny person with
any kind of job can relate that you know
sometimes you have to say yes when you
really want to say no sometimes that gig
that comes across the table isn't quite
what you want but you hope that it leads
to bigger and better things and as you
can see my manager kind of
[Music]
he kind of misguides me sometimes and I
take the bait your back torn again yeah
we tore us boys to men and Paula Abdul
this May June and July and yeah we're
together yeah we're out there together
and we've been very lucky I mean this
time the first time around with the new
kids was amazing but this time we're
together this time around longer than
the last time and it's we got the best
fans in the world and they have a lot of
good times it's it's the same fans right
yeah oh yeah they're all gonna now now
we want to brainwash the next generation
so we want to bring the next generation
in and that's going pretty well so we
got some younger kids in the crowd - is
it fun singing the old hits is there
something that you can't stand singing
anymore something that you love singing
ah not necessarily I mean we don't
there's something we're lucky to have
ten yeah it records that we could let in
cues from yeah and so uh yeah so we're
we're lucky yeah and we enjoy it and we
you know we try to you know mix it up
with some new stuff too but we embrace
the past I mean look at these look at
the video that video yeah that was the
very very first video that we made for
that Michael Hall isn't it that's maybe
we can it can be if you like I think
it's I think it's the bright 80s colors
that year is throwing you off a little
bit no kasha odd then is it weird does
that chapter of your life seem far away
I guess it's like high school like like
people would look at their yearbooks you
know what I mean it's a little kind of
funny and I mean at this point we we you
know look at it with the open heart you
know all that nostalgia is it's kind of
fun to look at you're you're funny
I mean I think people know that you're
very gifted but you're funny
thank you did you have to convince
people no no really I can I can do this
a little bit I mean I've been lucky I've
had some some good acting gigs and you
just kind of want to build that resume
and I guess it's led to this too you
know you got to make it happen though I
created this show with your executive
producer yeah yeah along with Donnie
Wahlberg who's here with you guys quite
off
with blue buds and stuff so it's been a
great experience I've learned a ton
anything else you want to do uh tap
dance no come on yeah oh well I love
that I love the theater I grew up in the
theater so so so I you know I've done a
few things in New York and my wife's
room here so but it's expensive I don't
know if we want to go back to three
rooms you know in Manhattan when we have
you know a little bit of a yard in LA so
it's a tricky but love the city and yeah
well good luck on the tour thank you
tell everybody we said hi I will yes I
will see him out on that yeah things
days yes
return of the Mack premieres tomorrow
night on top TV that is a division of
CBS